[Musique]
la droite du
très dur trop
longtemps vos droit selon la droite
Chanel appentin 103 licenciements Lipton
éléphant à geménos 57 suppressions
d'emplois Alcatel Lucent 4500 emplois
supprimés en Europe pbco à saint-disier
45 salariés sur le carreau Airbus et ses
sous-traitants 10000 postes supprimés
avec la droite vous avez le droit d'être
au
chômage après la date du 15 mars sous
les expulsions repris effectivement euh
une demande de logements sociaux est
indispensable dans la mesure où il y a
des tonnes de sansabris et où les
promoteurs aujourd'hui s'en don à cord
joie sur le logement nous ce qu'on
demande c'est qu'on construise pas qu'on
démolisse et surtout un grand Surice
public pour le logement avec la droite
vous avez le droit d'être à la
rue les retraités vivent mal ils ne
partent pas en vacances ils ne prennent
pas de loisirs
ne participe pas aux initiatives de
culture parce qu'elles vivent notamment
les femmes avec 600 € voire 900 €
mensuels il faut 1500 € minimum de
retraite le plus vite possible avec la
droite vous avez le droit d'être
pauvre la création artistique souffre du
manque de moyens moins de production
moins d'emploi des contrats à très
courte durée les professionnels sont en
situation précaire c'est toute la
culture qui est attaquée par la logique
commerciale avec la droite vous avez le
droit d'être
précaire l'extrême droite en rêve la
droite c'est le faire il y a plusieurs
manières d'exclure les gens par exemple
en enfermant les travailleurs étrangers
dans la clandestinité ou en raflant
leurs enfants jusqu'au portes des écoles
on peut aussi faire des amalgames entre
jeunes des banlieux et racaill entre
immigration et insécurité
ou refuser à des couples de même sexe le
droit d'adopter d'élever des enfant ou
encore vouloir créer une santé pour les
riches et une pour les pauvres la liste
est sans fin et inacceptable avec la
droite vous avez le droit d'être
exclu depuis 5 ans la droite a enclenché
la régression des droits sociaux pour
beaucoup la vie est très dure pour la
jeunesse trouver un travail une bonne
formation c'est le parcours du
combattant la droite tente de précariser
à vie tous les salariés le droit à la
retraite au logement à la santé ces
droits fondamentaux sont dans le viseur
de Sarkozy et de son frère jumeau berou
ils veulent construire une société du
profit où l'humain ne compte plus à ces
inégalités sociales s'ajoutent les
discriminations qui portent atteinte à
la dignité des personnes les femmes sont
payées 21 % de moins que les hommes à
formation égale un jeune issu d'un
quartier populaire aura moins de chance
de trouver un emploi nous méritons mieux
qu'une société de violence
économique nous nous voulons une société
solidaire la solidarité est une valeur
fondamentale que nous voulons faire
vivre concrètement nous soutenons
l'économie sociale et solidaire qui
démocratise l'économie à partir de
l'engagement des citoyens elle génère
des créations d'emploi soutient les
personnes fragilisé et participe à des
projets
utiles nous voulons une société pour
vivre ensemble 1500 milliards d'euros
c'est le total des transactions
financières qui sont opérées chaque jour
dans le monde d'un autre côté la moitié
de l'humanité vit avec moins d'un € par
jour et elle en meurt si la communauté
internationale décide de prélever une
taxe sur ses opération financière elle
peut constituer un fond qui permettra
l'accès à l'eau à l'alimentation à la
santé et à l'éducation des habitants des
pays en voie de développement vivre
ensemble c'est soutenir le développement
équitable remettre la droite au pouvoir
c'est lui donner le feu vert pour
accélérer sa politique de destruction
sociale de recul démocratique ce monde
libéral marche sur la tête alors stop ou
encore je propose une logique nouvelle
une société tournée vers la satisfaction
des besoins humains et du respect de
notre environnement une société qui
lutte contre les discriminations sex6 et
homophobe notre pays est riche riche de
votre travail notre pays est malade de
la loi de l'argent en matière de revenus
d'emploi de retraite de protection
social je propose de garantir les droits
qui permettent de vivre tout simplement
l'égalité d'E à une bonne éducation à
des conditions de vie dignes ne doivent
plus être réservé à quelques-uns dans
cette campagne beaucoup d'entre vous me
disent leur soutien au programme que je
défends et pourtant hésite je vous pose
cette question qui vous défendra demain
qui portera vos revendication vos
espoirs la gauche peut et doit gagner
pour qu'elle réponde à vos attentes
donnez-nous la force de vous défendre je
suis engager pour battre la droite et
l'extrême droite et réussir à gauche
votre vote compte au premier tour pour
une France sociale pour une gauche
courageuse au premier tour le vote utile
c'est celui qui porte vos aspirations
pour une gauche fidèle à ses valeurs
déterminé à changer la vie le 22 avril
le vote de gauche marieorge
[Musique]
buffet